what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight prediction video today I want to
talk about some of the characters we did
not see during season seven and in some
cases we haven't seen some of them for
multiple seasons so the chances of them
coming back into the main plot aren't
looking too good but hey who knows maybe
they will work themselves back into the
story somehow I'm sure there are a few
characters that I'm gonna be forgetting
but I just wanted to briefly go over
some of the missing characters and talk
about whether or not these loose ends
will be resolved the first character on
my list is Jack and Hegar he has been
missing the least amount of time
considering we did see him near the end
of season six but when we last saw Jack
and it didn't seem like it was going to
be the end of his character especially
since he had such a great interest in
Arya Stark I think there are a few
different ways Jack and could pop back
up in the show although it may not be
likely the most obvious way of course
would have something to do with Arya
Stark but they could also introduce
apart from the books that has to do with
the Citadel and possibly even Daenerys
Targaryen and her dragons many people
believe Jack and agar is at the Citadel
in search of a book that has something
to do with the death of Dragons
now that the Dragons are as dangerous as
ever in the night King has a dragon of
his own the urgency of getting rid of
these dragons has increased tremendously
so maybe this is a possibility all I
know is Jack and agar seems to be a
beloved character by many and it would
be interesting to see if he and Oreo
will ever cross paths again the only
problem is there is a much time with
only six episodes left to tie everything
up in a nice bow they will have to
decide who they want to include in the
story the second character on my list is
kin vara she was last seen in season six
as well and although her scene was short
it did have a pretty big impact what she
said to Varys when they met seemed to be
foreshadowing something we could see
come to fruition in a later season what
Varys heard in the flames as a little
boy has haunted him his entire life and
can vara knows what was said in she told
Varys as long as he supports Daenerys
then he has nothing to fear from her
these words visibly shook Varys to his
core and it may have been foreshadowing
a betrayal coming from Varys not to
mention what Melisandre said to Varys
right before she left
volantis which is where can fara most
likely is right now Melisandre said she
was going to volantis but she would
return and she knew when she returns to
Westeros she was going to die there at
some point as what Varys
when Melisandre returned she may have
conveyor with her and if Varys begins to
betray Daenerys this may be the end of
the road for him I just hope can Vora
reveals what was said to Varys in the
flames when the sorcerer tossed his
parts into the brazier I think the
chances of Canberra returning in season
8 what Melisandre is pretty high right
now let's just hope it happens next on
the list is Daenerys Targaryen former
sugar daddy
also known as Illyrio my memory isn't
quite as clear about him as some others
but as far as I remember we haven't seen
him since season 1 back when arya spied
on him and Varys walking through the
crypts of the red key we did see his
palace again during season 5 because
that's where Varys took Tyrion when they
fled King's Landing together but Illyria
was not seen during that time and his
whereabouts as of right now are unknown
this man was a pretty important
character in the first season but he
just vanished from the story since then
Illyrio had kept an heiress and Varys
safe as they tried to reclaim their
power he also helped arrange the wedding
between Daenerys and Khal Drogo and
arguably most importantly he was the one
who gifted Daenerys with her dragon eggs
now that Daenerys is in Westeros and her
dragons are fully grown you'd think he'd
want to check in on her from time to
time but I guess there was no room for
his character anymore so the chances of
seeing him again are probably pretty
slim another character we haven't seen
since season 6 is Howland Reed father of
Meera and Jojen Reed and arguably one of
the Starks most loyal bannermen this is
the man who'd Ned trusted with his
deepest and darkest secret which was the
truth about Jon Snow's parents thanks to
the flashback scene this was confirmed
but other than that we haven't seen or
heard from Howland Reed since
considering he is one of Ned's most
trusted men you would think he could
have made an appearance when the stark
family had been in trouble for all of
these years now just to be fair he
hasn't seen or heard from much in the
books either but he did send his
children on behalf of him and that's
when they helped escort bran north of
the wall to the three-eyed raven now
that the series is
coming to an end you have to wonder if
we will ever see this character in the
present day and not just a flashback
with the army of the Dead approaching
Winterfell the Starks will need to call
all of their banners once again and
considering Mira was heading home there
is a chance she might return to help and
hopefully she brings her father with her
not only could they help in the war to
come but he could also help clear up any
suspicions about John's legitimacy and
claim to the throne it's gonna be
interesting to see if they do anything
with this character or not because I
would like to see him again next on my
list is the despicable sir Ilyn Payne
the executioner who took Ned Stark's
head with his own Valyrian steel sword
ice this is something I will never
forgive him for but that doesn't mean I
don't want to see him again he was last
seen during the Battle of Blackwater Bay
and although he has not died in the show
he was when Arya Starks hitless for
taking her father's head unfortunately
the actor who portrayed this character
ended up getting cancer and from what I
read it was pretty serious but I also
read that he did have an operation and
he is now cancer-free which is great
news but when it comes to his character
we probably won't ever see him again
even if they did recast him also the
last time Arya recited her list was in
season six and she did not mention sir
Ellen's name so that might mean he is
not going to be coming back to the show
another character we haven't seen since
season six is good old ed mere Tully in
my opinion he was in one of the most
well acted scenes during season six when
him and Jamie spoke in the tent right
outside the Riverrun castle but i won't
go into this too much because i have
spoke about this already in previous
videos regarding Riverrun and the
possible use of its castle during season
eight I think everyone already knows
that Muir should still be alive and
there was really no reason why we
shouldn't see him again considering
Jaime is heading north he may stop and
get whoever he can to go with him to
help defend the realm plus the Starks
are going to be calling all of their
banners anyway the only problem is Ed
mere may not be important enough to show
on screen again so this may be another
character that gets left on the
sidelines but we shall see now this next
character is a very mysterious one in
the show in in the books and that is
Quaithe the masked woman from the shadow
lands beyond - I
personally this is a character I would
love to see again because she was very
interesting when she was on the screen
and she always hinted at something more
especially with her warnings to Sir
Jorah Mormont but I think it's safe to
say that even some book readers may be
unsure of Quast true intentions but she
talks to Daenerys Targaryen about
prophecies that have yet to be fully
revealed and I am curious to know what
the endgame is gonna be with this
mysterious character I think the chances
of seeing her again in the show might be
slim but I won't rule anything out just
yet with the night king coming for
everyone I won't be surprised who shows
up in the end to provide some kind of
help or service I also can't forget
about everyone's favorite character
little sweet Robin Arryn lord of the
Vale if Westeros wasn't in complete
chaos right now he would most likely be
warden of the east making him an even
more powerful player in this game all
kidding aside I hate this little [ __ ]
and I would guess most of you do too but
that doesn't take away from the fact
that this character should be given some
kind of closure he is Lord of the Vale
after all and now that Littlefinger is
dead he won't have any influence over
his decisions the Knights of the Vale
were his and they are largely
responsible for winning the Battle of
the bastards they are a decent-sized
force who are trained to fight in the
snow and they should be a formidable
force when it comes time to fight the
night King there isn't any real reason
why we shouldn't see Robin again unless
they just give full control to yon Royce
and leave Robin on the sidelines like
many other characters are now another
person I must mention is Davos his
long-lost friends salad or sand I
believe the last time we saw him was
during season 4 after Davos and Stannis
got there alone from the iron bank
Davos visited him in a cozy little
bathhouse and hired him to escort
Stannis's sell swords up to the wall
since then he has not really been seen
but there is a tiny glimmer of hope that
he could pop up again Salladhor sands
most of his time on the sea in during
season eight there is going to be a lot
of activity on the sea Jon and Daenerys
are travelling by boat as we speak and
so is Theon plus Euron will be sailing
to pick up the golden company and come
back to Westeros Melisandre will also
make her way back from volantis as well
so who really knows maybe he comes back
for one last scene since so many people
are going to be traveling by
Oh someone might actually run into him
but if anyone is gonna find him it's
most likely gonna be Davos maybe after
all the fighting is over Davos decides
to get the hell out of Westeros for a
while and he can hitch a ride with his
old pal
but as you can see there are still a lot
of unresolved storylines that have been
left open over the years and with
everyone moving around in this final
season I think there is still a chance
we may see some of them again especially
after the wars are over
in the final episode we should see
everyone who has survived come together
in some way to try and rebuild and
restore some sort of normalcy if any way
possible I'm not gonna row anything out
just yet but I guess we're just gonna
have to wait and see from this list
which character or characters do you
think is most likely to make a return
before it's all said and done put your
answer down in the comments let's see
who can guess it right I want to thank
you all for watching the video I
appreciate that as always and I also
want to thank all of you kind people
that support this channel on patreon I
hope everybody has a great day I'll see
you in the next one bye
[Music]
you